so far we've seen success with loading
image data but it would be great if we
could extend this functionality into
loading javascript files too the good
news is that you can add a javascript
file to the dom dynamically and just
like with images you get a callback
function once the file has been loaded
so what you need to do now is to fill in
the rest of this code to allow the load
assets function to take a list of file
names which might be images or
javascript and load them correctly which
means is that in here before we actually
issue off our command we need to figure
out what type of file we're trying to
load tricky tricky you may have to look
at the file names extension to determine
this